[Music]
what is up everybody
happy Monday welcome back GameSpot live
we are here we are checking it up carry
on today the demo that released last
week Ritchie and I were playing a bunch
of spooky games but in this
quote-unquote
reverse horror game you're the monster
we're gonna go eat some innocent
bystanders and you will hack everyone
actually we like our monsters we broke
out of there you know grasp so
technically you know they're not that
innocent right
not at all we are a lab experiment gone
wrong and we're gonna eat everybody so
I'm actually pretty excited to check it
out this is a demo so um we're not
really sure how long it is but we're
gonna play as much of it as we can let's
find out with y'all
so let's do it
all right so left mouse button to move
what up so chilled what up chat happy
Monday everybody thanks for tuning in
okay so I'm just just using the mouse
and I'm a little like this I'm little
you I'm this little thing but you grow I
saw that we all if you guys watch the
trailer you know that you just grown to
this massive awful thing with team
grab objects so yes this is pre new game
it's not officially released yet this is
an alpha demo that's now available on
Steam that just came out last week that
one thing about the trailer that I love
is like the humans are terrified and
they're like screaming now do i and then
pull them like into your mouth really
quit yelling cool now I'm a little
bigger look at that it's just like a
very nasty like a flesh blob or
something yeah what's that game though
Kumari I think I'm too weak to bust this
down yeah we must consume more flesh
yeah and you're like a blob that can
just like go through all these little
crevices and stuff oh this guy's got a
weapon yeah but look I can't bust
through this wall yes you can't crunch
it no all right let's go explore it okay
we got it we got to evolve yeah we do
Oh hook oh thanks can I go here
yeah yes I can Vince continuing to be
terrifying oh these guys are strapped
yeah they're armed they're looking for
you they won't find me I'll find them
Nate's games press space oh that's like
a sorry y'all it just got out of crunch
yeah what the heck your mouth remember
yeah
I'm not done with you yet boy finish
your plate hey there you go playing with
my food here y'all francis like what is
that my thoughts oh oh I'm actually
surprised it took only like 2 shots are
you okay confirm that is a safe point
good because I'm not very far time to
take revenge Brandon said carry on my
wayward son right oh that song was stuck
in my head after I watch this trailer I
gotta attack him first that and then
disarm them encourage munch munch munch
I think of you when you flick it and
hold it and then drag them into your
mouth you're absolutely right
I'm glad you're here what is it a
chewing yeah you are a blob that is
actually terrifying imagine being a
human stuck in there and you just see
him like just numb in the way
crunch-crunch-crunch oh I know you're
still screaming Katamari exactly here
comes a train chance oh it's it's
probably better with the joypad instead
of a mouse I'm okay I think
yeah I'm doing fine having a casual
snack this is for PC by the way I see
that question in chat yeah oh oh oh my
gosh you want to give it a shot oh all
right let's see you pass in the mouth
yeah grab mal seizure you're good maybe
I might run and get a joypad or a
pattern someday yeah yeah I won't mind
I'll grab one for my desk if you want to
try it out French French
Travis says the spaghetti is alive
basically and it's gonna eat you bro mmm
I forget how you regain health or if it
comes back on its own but these guys got
to go expected release date Brandon 2020
at some point but I forget when do you
know Persia
they should play Katamari music with
this you should swap their audio Alex
hey you know what let's just figure this
out right now a lot of people are asking
when this one this is coming out I will
look it up for y'all because I like all
I know is 2020 so let's figure it out
all it says 2020 let me check the actual
let me click further into the game
studio phobia game studio shield is
operative and may fry incautious
maintainer x' within seconds danger the
turrets shield is okay so the shield so
okay Nikki hey there's a turret B it has
a shield go with caution purge Oh
hmm there it goes see me there he goes
he's looking around
no way I'm there on their site it just
says 2020 coming 2020 so there's no hard
details yet but the this alpha is out
now to play I don't think we like it's
up for everyone right person right it
just came out Alex K asks how does it
how does it feel to control looks a
little floaty what a mouse I think
that's probably why it feels that way
but I do think they want you to be like
a free roaming like symbiotes I
craziness
I think it's yes meant to be a little
floaty but yours if you want I'll grab
that controller we can test it both that
maybe I'm running grab one yeah we can
do like you know a comparison yeah see
what we think of both cuz we're getting
questions about both yeah
I'll be right back oh I went all the way
back to the start
pretty good though kill it with fire I
did see in the trailer that there was
like oh I forgot you can eat the light I
did see in the trailer there was one
thing that was English sentence oh that
there were people with flamethrowers
like this guy right here actually yeah
where do we get more humans to eat let's
go over here
oh they like sounds though are
definitely intense chains oh okay I
think I found our killed
ow he's like shooting my noodles off I
[Laughter]
made it past the turret but you just
shoot with some of my noodles off no oh
okay I have to run into the water wow
I'm tiny again okay get this fool Oh No
all right I won't plug this into you're
ready but I have you are it's okay we'll
get him back
I like the whipping sound like yeah all
right all right
so let's let's switch it real quick okay
I wonder if there will be anything
references in the game well they didn't
start us off with any type of cutscenes
or anything so alright we plugged them
in the joypad they gave the controller
it's not responding yet really maybe you
have to go back to like it's a mini
anything maybe I don't know oh oh oh
wait get out of here what did I do
bummer let's see in the back maybe you
can't oh I did it again
maybe you can't use controller on there
or maybe not or maybe we have to start
it like from the beginning
oh I don't want to have to do that oh I
don't know what do you think for now you
see yeah we'll just stick with the with
the mouse first sure because I want to
waste any precious moments of eating
humans there's a whom is we are
spaghetti killer spaghetti says Francis
indeed what up Francis thank you for
joining us oh he's our P with fire a
little barrier there D boy in the chat
he says hi yes Adam this game is
currently being played on PC
we're playing the alpha I don't know if
it's available anywhere else at the
moment it's planned later on got to wash
my food before I eat it Carlos we tried
the controller we're gonna we might try
again a little later but normally it
works right away didn't work I can only
just toss them around really maybe it's
his armor oh yeah I don't like that guy
his blood is everywhere
you're next homie
alright noted next time I see some
killer spaghetti fire right Nate says
this game reminds me a lot of venom and
carnage but without taking over the
hosts yeah you kind of just eat them and
move on grow a little bigger yeah we
lead him around
alright this room cleared
yeah get that you need to try another
USB port
lights out fool see you now we're
getting to the root of this like this is
like a lab but like were we created we
kind of just started in that weird like
yes oh no it is I've Unleashed it to get
through this game hey a little safe
Wayne if you want to use it down below
there was a yeah press space for me oh
yeah yeah save point here use the middle
mouse button to shoot at cobweb oh I'm
not trying to do we have that power you
[Music]
curious let me know oh it's this press
space again let me know if you want me
to do that for you yeah oh okay you
might be able to like unlock the secrets
oh you got a skill yeah damage vents and
wooden walls okay now we can get through
middle mouse button hold it to use it
also cool it's going like this boy oh oh
if you don't know
[Music]
alright alright I'm evolving
you are alert yeah this is totally like
a things you have heck eyeballs and
teeth I'm a big spaghetti thick noodles
mm-hmm
Bob Jones in the chat so you can
reproduce you will be able to take over
this one oh my goodness oh that guy's
ready I know
turn around you don't know we're here
yeah there you go yeah
oh no more guns there we go Oh No there
we go boys fooled with guns very nice
but the screaming is thought I just kind
of run over them on like disorient them
a bit
[Music]
like a Mickey getting up so I respect
that
yeah let's get back to our full-size I
know oh I like that oh this guy's still
brave enough to take it on with a little
handgun get these games breath um yum
feast feast I'm Alex Kane the chat says
kind of reminds me of one of those
grower games like most metal it's like
the most metal Katamari yeah oh yeah I
am deadly now yeah yeah next room ooh
you're all of these if you need there
you go okay yeah it looks like these are
like tiny one Oh exact thing when I'm in
the water I can oh wait what I do oh wow
they really want you to like travel and
go back to certain places that like
lever was really far from wherever that
so when I'm in the water I can disperse
into little noodles and get through
these passages that's fun okay that's
good to know you need to raise the water
level is what that's telling you yeah
only within water it looks like there's
a switch up there oh okay
so so hmm probably have to come back
around from that side so I can go
through there yeah you can use that cool
wooden thing oh no I think you tried
already a happier web there we go these
games there's too many places ago since
I'm just constantly touring like I like
that though Oh
[Music]
he heard that my nudes no he's not happy
Oh what would you go Alex Kate Alex came
to chat yeah you can take my money
that's crazy you can bamboozle these
fools what happens if I randomly press
space just checking
no no if I did that no they'd go up or
down
naari bite yeah we'll figure it out not
fire though yeah do that kills you quick
you're in the right yeah look where you
are now perfect with that switch there
you go
Francis in the chat somebody touch my
spaghetti yeah that looks like they'd be
totally easy to get through ooh yeah a
reason yeah way actually no this is fine
don't wait down I thought so too had the
same thought all right let's see hard
block yeah dang okay
nudes Oh
all right Shawn leave Riggs in the chat
yeah I needed this yesterday he's
excited okay let's see if we can see the
pattern here losers losers Bob Jones
asked you get soggy in water
yeah pretty much a little bit huh kind
of like but you it helps you get through
some specific walls if you're if you're
in that soggy state if you're cooked
spaghetti if you will or boiling
spaghetti okay place to what I can say
our progress yeah there we go
and another safe spot up there munch
munch munch I like the teeth yeah icon
[Applause]
Great Hall let me know right there so
we're just like opening up new safe
parts I think that'll be helpful later
sigh and the chat says good looking game
yeah I agree I agree too oh dang Chrissy
let me go back okay
Swift noodle there you go actually like
that it breaks up yeah hmm oh we
remember where that man they come back
they respond
Alex K says this should be called
Chipotle day - hey here we go
I did it okay oh there it is
so teeny what well I want more me too
dang that was what uh dang let's try to
see if we can get the controller to work
yeah and try it out on pad we're just
too good I just use more areas in there
that we could have gone to that I just
didn't yeah we didn't the objective
early yeah can fight the Germans ooh oh
you're right I should have been my
little web thingy on them web swing okay
here I'll put it on
this screen and then we'll exit and
start it again with the pad already okay
hooked up and we'll see but you know
even though we beat it pretty quickly
it's really fun and I definitely want
yeah that's me in control yeah all right
we did it press now is this is not from
the beginning we were we're a big
spaghetti here Alex Kay that if this is
the first person game and you were a
security guard that'd be hilarious
that'd be terrible hilarious here yeah
we gotta figure out which button is your
super web on the board oh my god super
web
it looks like our be my right bumper
what's the Mudge button yeah I think so
oh now it tells me om the rights they
can hold right trigger to grab yank the
right stick to interact with
that looks like a one-way tube here yep
yep oh we sort of fudged it and we're
playing again oh yeah maybe we should
start a new one
sure okay let's see here oops wrong
button amused to the ps4 I think start
the demo yeah there we go for all of you
guys who just joined us we can watch it
again now we're playing with the
controller mm-hmm here we go I'm a
little spaghetti and guys if you haven't
seen the trailer I highly recommend
going and watching it because it shows
you know not really a ton of story stuff
but you get a little bit more context
like this little noodle noodle Ness
breaks out and he's out for ribbon right
hey it's not like the right Mouse it's
not clicking like it was before right
stick and then hold Artie
you know what for it was crazy how with
less funds it was more intuitive right
now just like goofing off here where's
the help
right stick yeah okay aim at it and then
like press the right trigger to activate
your chompers okay how's it feel with
the controller Oh purchase got it
already
look at that pro monster
I love the rag doll miss oh yeah
LS in the chat says hi hello hello I
need every bit so I can get these games
so you can grow big and strong yeah I
feel like these controls aren't too bad
either I did was a little easier with
the mouse thank you glad we got the
controller to work though in general oh
right innocent people it's garbage day
no free lunch yeah a lot more quiet now
they're all ripped to pieces yeah I feel
like the I actually feel like the mouse
you know I thought so too maybe because
we played with it first I don't know
yeah yeah well for you I was like oh
these guys right here knows me yeah that
was one of them was actually me trying
to play this on the computer like this
and then it's got no music or anything
there you go the way around them
I want my super ability nay warka knave
and the chat says this looks like a lot
this looks a lot like another phobia
developed game called butcher okay
well if it same thing like this this is
I know Plus that copier thing time to
grow big and strong
mm hey when you get that cool super I
know I don't even remember where we were
last Daniel with more of a little deep
cut here he says reminds me a lot of the
worm infected boar from Princess
Mononoke whoa
haven't heard oh man Minna Watson's I
thought of that movie that's all I'm
thinking I really appreciate the sound
effects Captain H pig pig this game is
called carry on it's right below us on
the the YouTube video here you really
want it right now there is an alpha
build out for PC you can play it just
like us it's not the full game we want
the full game too but it comes out 2020
sometime in 2020
Alex K I can't wait for this monster to
get added to dying light I would just
ruin everything in like a cool way Oh P
you know that barrier he straight-up
waved at him oh no his fire
[Music]
you goofed there you go now we're gonna
like a extra throwing him around like I
don't know if I can't eat those guys
completely yeah something about their
suit I think all right those guys got
body hose dude devoured if you will
moving on up is it me or I felt like we
learned that cool web power early on
last time yeah there you go
Oh century
I love the 2d look at this it's like a
really well it's a really good looking
2d game I love these kind of games oh I
think I learned it here
Persia was this demo available for free
right yes okay I'm steam it is available
now free go free alex que with with the
really beep a really deep thought here
it's like the blob and the thing had a
terrible relationship and thought having
a kid would solve their problems
good lord and then de katie i know this
is a story line here screenwriter bro
alex Kade's got all the clocks there you
go see you were able to break water yeah
yeah she's kind of satisfied roller
destroy everything I can't wait to play
the full game to see how big you can get
like if the screen zoomed out because
you're too big or I'm also got that
flick George of the jungle your way
through this lab Daniel asked this will
come out the consoles I think it will
close to you oh no oh my gosh I can't
use my super abilities the new get my
health back through consumption of human
body come over here don't look at me gun
can attract all of my food sources into
here yes
according to devolver digital the via
publisher it says coming to PC and
consoles in 2020 be on the look out
maybe follow them on Twitter or
something you got them all though right
crunch-crunch-crunch he's like this is
your corner like hey you're gaining your
powers okay or some bar up there it's
full to the max maybe this is your
fullest size yeah
I don't know in the trailer I see you
like definitely a big ol massive blob
man he regular grab that one oh you just
busted through there cool I mean if I
was a lab experience experiment held
captive I would do this just rage yeah I
mean you've seen the thing right you let
me get out you done messed up yeah
exactly have you seen the thing it's
pretty much like this although the thing
like can shape-shift a little bit oh I
thought I was
Daniel take my money devolver here's my
whole wallet daniel is hype for this
game to be fair so am i I know I watch
the demo but actually playing it is
something else this looks really fun
press a it said oh I think there was a
door there oh that's funny that's where
you are yeah oh that's so funny look at
Seattle there's a Space Needle Oh Brian
we don't know exactly when it comes out
we tried looking at the website just
says 2020 man but yeah it does look
amazing you should play this alpha it's
available on PC yes what did you spare
one guy share my legacy
you threw a body part of him and he got
knocked out even heard of Mark Harris I
think this is coming to the switch as
far as I know I think I saw a game play
for it first actually on this way like
someone's head
really Oh someone's gun head leg oh man
what now I'm like tossing my food around
Sebastian says the stranger thing season
3 for real if I do get stranger things
by was especially since um they just
released that like 8-bit game - oh yeah
I played the very first one when it was
like mobile only I mean I didn't play
the other - did you no no it was the
first one was cool it's like a look like
a Super Nintendo game I went to and they
had like a stranger things Pawnee house
was it cool it was oh cool good to hear
it was good but there's like these kids
in front of us who kept like
snapchatting and with the flash on and
I'm like no phobia game studio
headquarters butcher release carry on
release that's funny you see that check
we don't have the answers y'all 2020 is
all we've got
it's all blacked out both clever your
empire in the chat says I made spaghetti
that behaved like that once
oh all right
mission accomplished here I guess we got
to find more doors like that yeah that
was cool I don't remember that room from
the last time at all yeah we did not go
in there you got to be on the lookout
for that little press a there's like a
little doorway dougie and the chat says
what is this
this is carry-on you played the monster
this thing you eat everybody and it's
awesome this demo is available on Steam
right now so if you like what you see
you should check it out or stick around
okay to attack it oh that turret I'm
just
yeah my god that guy's dead alright but
I'm just so fat now I'm just running
this is like me running into everything
like I always Nick corners and smack
everything on my way that stupid little
I hate that moving turret thing I'm like
I'm a true monster now cuz I'm like I
really need more how does the controller
feel it feels good I'll I've been you
know using it a little bit the mouse
definitely felt super intuitive off of
that yes that I agree with and then I
was handed to control and I was like
yeah you guys missed it if he didn't do
that there you go oh that guy oh oh I
forgot about that
Alex chaos Oh can you break the lights
first oh yeah it looks like we were
accidentally busting some lights but uh
[Music]
those gonna turn around oh okay you're
playing safe that's good Tyrande set
system to be perfect on the nintendo
switch you agree I think it's both I
think it's playing for it too
yep the sound work although subtle is
very cool yeah I think we can't sneak up
on them but we like to go in with a bang
and it's probably kind of hard to sneak
up on them since you're so massive but
I'm pretty sure you like waved at him my
life is funny says do you guys think
this is suitable for multiplayer yeah
I'm not thought of that I think it's
probably best played single-player but
if they can work out some multiplayer
yeah like split screen it has to be
split screen that'd be pretty fun Alex
Kate says if the final boss is samus I
will flip out we are Metroid your mother
brain just kind of like noodley Oh
you think this throwing those things
will do anything I don't want you to
can't get yourself killed but you have
before though I think right yeah look
you just gonna knock them like a soccer
ball - it is nice to calmly explore -
mmm-hmm
we had guys broom yeah hmm is there an
interest at the tippy-top in the middle
here like that
Oh Mike no it's nothing okay kind of
looks like a area secret wait I wonder
if there's another secret doorway see
Bridge buoy this is our makeup day right
this is a spooky enough we get to be the
speech dude this time yeah take that
slurp yeah it's over like I was just
like covering his head like
Oh worst day at work Pharrell last day I
worked in case of the Mondays this is a
perfect Monday game ooh me after this
dream I go get lunch
she's gonna see me like hanging on the
ceiling eating my burger there you go
not gonna go in there just yet
didn't that end the demo we got some
time oh it's just all stuffed in there
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
Frances is the chat says the spaghetti
monster just keeps asking why are you
running
why are you running and I get so sore
like ah ah all the humans ooh well your
little I can't use my super ability
right now did you pull it switch oh yeah
I think you did earlier oh I get full
health really oh yeah thank you
wait where'd it go it disappeared
checkpoint what's go you didn't kill him
I didn't but he's gone he go up he was
[ __ ] man is that really all of it I
don't want it to be over you killed
everyone
no oh wait we have to be able to make
this water rise now
yeah you haven't done that yet oh wait
looks like you hmm
we've been to this part
whoa did I like go through that and then
now I go oh it's one way okay Oh fine
nope oh yeah that helped us out earlier
in combat I like what you're thinking
though yeah maybe you can like budget no
but I want to see more places like that
like maybe there are more secret little
areas yeah devolver digital is like over
no no don't go there boo the rest of
that guy little snack now that there's
no one around ding what is he I guess
that was the point he was a teacher the
way you get addicted yeah okay sold I
can't wait for this to come out
Oh
[Music]
I thought it was like I thought it was
too super okay I guess that is it I
guess that's all what about the rest of
this room oh you did okay good times we
were one strand of pasta okay oh yeah
okay this was cool good times were
already reminiscing we've we've played
the F out of this I want to ruin the
world Seattle specifically I like I was
still rainy - yeah hmm the old lab Oh
oh I want to kill it I don't know oh no
back to the save spots like and regain
my health yeah behold once again was
somewhere up here yeah what I thought it
was
oh yeah oh yeah well y'all I think we've
done all we could do you've tried it
once on Mouse tried once on controller
still can't get enough yeah I know I'm
so sad but now without people it's like
sad twenty uh or obstacles even like we
every door has been open think I love
you can hear every individual tap of
like mice that gets hitting the rap
there it is okay maybe in the game like
you leave the lab after this whoo yeah
you're welcome
that was great thank you yeah thank you
huh so interesting what do you guys
think yeah how you guys feel about this
game or you guys want to download it
yourself or we want the full game for
sure we can't wait I know did I find the
Easter Egg the Easter was it are you
talking about the studio room because we
did find like a secret door and it took
us to their studio headquarters and we
ate everyone is great it was pretty
satisfying I kind of want to like having
a room just filled with like hundreds
and hundreds of bodies just like in my
grandma yeah I got close there was like
oh my god there were a lot of people in
one room and you just kind of threw
everyone around that was probably like
one of the highlights I was great yeah
Moe res this game is in alpha mode on PC
right now it's on Steam that's how we're
playing actually it is the sneak peek
and it's good you should try it out
longer I mean it's not a bad thing it
just makes me one more shame and we
still have like time left in the stream
you might have to cut it early if this
is the keys but yeah what's she thinking
here I've never had this issue again
Mouse speedrun okay fine you know what
I'll grab the mouse we'll do it one more
time okay you got some time to kill you
know you it will have Ritchie do a full
playthrough like I've been I've played
it a lot now this is all you chat let us
know what you think of this game if you
want to pick it up and what other games
this reminds you of because this is
awesome I'm alive and there's definitely
some sort of like locked ability on the
left that we don't even get to use yet
yeah we never explored that first
through and we always run through the
one-way ton oh really yeah
okay nope I don't have a safe how about
we just start over again yeah cuz I yeah
you're right we kind of just scooch past
that first room now we're like we must
find everything Easter Egg ever in this
demo on this alpha
okay this room is clear we at least have
to go back to the studio and wreak havoc
at least one more day yeah that was fun
look at how small oh this room that's
all there is okay up here yeah check in
the ground now that we're experts at
this game yeah exactly
now we're just uh aficionados yeah oh
yeah I'd like that better than the
controller which is weird it's like a 2d
you know uh platformer not platform well
sort of a side-scrolling game and it
should be like best honor control you'd
think yeah it's just the mouse is very
very intuitive oh man I just realized
he's taking the dumb guy he looked like
it was really stressful now I'm eating
them jeez it looks like Metroid Plus
dead space but you're the monster right
yeah this guy doesn't know what to do
oh he's locked let me help you figure
that out there okay I open the door nice
and polite wait let's explore every last
corner oh okay we yeah we can't go
through here yet so we get our - but
it's familiar territory okay I know
where we are now Oh carrion is actually
the name of the monster cool says
Captain H pigpig great name I remember
he was in chat earlier
ooh people I know it's kind of nice
seeing people locking her on again yeah
we try to be sneaky this time maybe I
think we've got a request for that in
the chat like a stealth it up or like is
that possible let's figure it out
let's go undetected a hundred percent
self run just kidding
they are pretty aware though like a
second little hand out there oh yeah
flamethrower guys saw me yeah or that
guy with the gun they just walk around
with guns no - right now yet not yet
okay gotta go find like that other tank
or something quietly watching oh this
guy oh look they're all down there
working consume humans to regain biomass
music order shoot everything that moves
and does not appear human okay
yum yum yum
wait oh no oh my - but I think if after
I eat them around here come here you
knock around first
yum yum yelling this computer there's no
hole pair of legs over there some
delicious and in some ways oh look a
hole where the legs mmm yum yum okay Oh
knocking him down is very important it
actually looked like your arms from you
just moving up there like knock them out
which was cool yeah just kind of like
smack them around okay let's go see if I
can find those oh no over the laser room
this thing can't be destroyed huh oh he
was saying is the monster called carry
on
I actually don't don't know oh we don't
know that's a good guess though okay
I've exact time little spaghetti if we
die on screen that beer first well
that's how it looks we did it for
research for science Oh back here this
is good times right yeah tackle you all
first drop your weapons
look at him he's on the ground he's
about to shoot you oh no I have to get
bigger first I can fight him you with a
gun over here mister gun over here hey
oh she's just witnessing all this I know
sorry
what is up leo
welcome to the chat hey leo Brad Bose
says I like the retro look to the game I
did same are the appeal it's fun I can't
yet okay whoa Laser room yep there yeah
yeah okay there's the water wait mm B of
Oh middle mouse button yeah yeah we
actually haven't used that much cuz once
you get the - you can't really use that
okay oh my God he's not around he
started running straight towards you
he's doing the right thing but like oh
no no one forgets on fire Oh
overcooked spaghetti there we go lost
contact with the homie hmm nope how
about under Neath yeah hmm yes are we
here first exploring okay those you're
like workarounds to you know get behind
them probably I like it so they want you
to do some stealth things at least yeah
I'll see what I can do next room I'll be
remember quietly gentle tug hmm oh
there's a switch like what's more
terrifying about this monster the fact
that you know he's smarter right because
we're controlling yeah
selfie no no no I can't - I'm song with
her he's broken whoo
weak faulty technology Oh here to your
right is where you get your - over here
whoa hey excuse me I'm like plate it
play through it twice yeah to the right
you're released okay up here in here you
got to break that middle thingy yeah
Oh destroy it there we go cool all right
middle mouse button holding yeah see
even the special ability on the mouse
seems way more does it go away
does my other ability go away I'm
checking the keyboard here possibly yeah
like that little like Spidey with
shooter yeah the thing is cool I didn't
use it nearly medically okay well I can
- they're all these right well if I'm
close enough
jeez you know let's go test it out here
we go human flesh yeah yeah splinters
everywhere
whoo okay any humans know bowling you
get it still holds the left mouse button
while you hold the middle one I'll hold
it okay that was a probably kept
clicking it like it was a spider web hmm
oh yes so long
Oh No safety bodies in here yep got to
focus on the guys with the guns unknown
biological structure found beneath the
complex oh boy I'm like reading all
their little alerts they have for their
employees like bulletin they did not
prepare them for this you may be Who I
am
[Applause]
come on cool hmm part of a complete
breakfast there you go
wait there we go tackle infers growing
okay I'm for dang heckle more bodies
yeah man I really wanna oh yeah this way
was to you the secret routes wait oh
wait no wait no all the blood everywhere
okay I can't do this yet cuz I know
there's no water not enough water well
that's where I was just now that's what
it I'm lost over here okay Alex case i
rated e for eat everything pretty much
love it yeah even the lights and
everything oh we're back to that
oh yes that's the very beginning right
there so much murdering Bob Jones such a
little time it is all we know wait
hmm okay we've been to that one right no
no yeah oh yeah go down oh yeah okay now
that I can bust through hey there we go
there we go yeah this was the way to the
Easter Egg really okay let's go yeah
there it is perfect okay let's go team
let's go eat all of them I like other
distances too yeah not a single one and
they have the release they covered up
with like boxes oh happy Halloween now
get back to work ruff he says oh the
boredom bored yet oh my gosh wait I want
to I still have the web oh that's cuz
you took some damage oh that's funny
I don't know there we go wait ah there
we go big and strong sorry you had to
see that
there we go there's one left
yeah sorry but I'm not I'm a monster
this is all I know how to do yeah there
we go
there's a release clever they gave us a
little audio cue there and once they
uncovered the release date door eating
the employees is not allowed Wow feeding
on the employees is allowed oh wait boys
not allowed feeding on the employees is
allowed yeah oh wow that's funny have
they indicated what the upgrades are
gonna be so frightened is Emma the only
upgrade we got was like the dashed at so
I'm actually not sure what what other
abilities they have in store for us
there's got to be more but yeah
definitely snooping around right what is
this corridor for mm-hmm all right
go I haven't been here yet in this
playthrough oh I hate that thing this
one can't die I think I'm trying to
break oh my gosh there we are you pulled
that switch
oh yeah dead soldiers oh yeah haven't
opened this little door wrong button but
that's okay oh yeah some of the spaces
really look like you can go in somewhere
yeah Nikki it's hopeful you know hoping
to find every last corner broke that
guy's computer mmm these seem to be my
biggest enemy there we go that's where
we learned our ability earlier where's
that switch for like the water room it's
somewhere around here yeah I think if
you go right on the top I mean left my
bed oh yeah up here like you have to go
I remember like around to the other side
is this that same water room it might be
oh yeah we're trying to get around so I
think you go back and then down down
left right yeah
oh yeah yeah here's a bad guy I mean a
good guy I guess
come here you oh no he's got a shield up
no oh yes he can shoot me from there
though I was so scared
Hey look he fell down a step I have the
teeth here can I grab him with the
shield wow he's actually in a great spot
dang it I'm so small oh yeah we keep
forgetting about that um captain said I
hope they have something where you can
slam them into floors and attack from
below and he's still here with me okay
God just chuck them around the fire
throws are actually pretty cheap because
you can't like feed on them to get your
health back just grow out of damage and
you have to run into the water to stop
the fire right
[Music]
like is there anything Oh
no just checking no we tried that she's
not an area ice which works like a
little hand I love it aren't armed I
know we extend no bueno now there we
embody those fools yeah especially you
you're seeing that now yeah
two places I'm a professional okay
now which way was that room actually is
there anything here before I move on it
was switch we okay good okay hmm
well there's no use being stealthy with
there you go cool he was cornered very
smart
well oh my arm
we out Oh is there any bodies I left
over look I'm so small no gonna see you
point that some creeps just switching
out
yeah oh man I'm so those long when you
go in the water you're a lone noodle
yeah oh and I'll walk myself out right
okay time to either face this thing or
die trying
I mean you can self pass them and then
go regain your health and then come back
for your revenge that's true he might
get the better when you're little you're
super fast so you can outrun them when
you're all thick no bodies but and see
if we can oh no bodies you said there's
checking their phones look Wow
wait I need all of you you're helping
trust me it's like they knew I needed
them yeah okay this door oh yeah you can
activate your little save point cool
any bugginess so far in the demo bill
actually no none at all then that I've
experienced not even with like both
controllers or the keyboard well it's
all pretty smooth you know you have to
love a naturally intuitive game you know
yeah yeah exactly
oh wait I don't want to kill that dumb
thing from earlier I was like why did I
need to get big because that dumb
machine didn't mean to me well there's
one more switch I forget where it is
have I use the safe nope nope
might as well is there anything below it
[Music]
okay the save points work as the
switches okay well I'll do one final
tour wait some crates here never broke
through nevermind
I won't I can't any more good people or
you know bad guys in this case we've
officially destroyed everyone three
times
that's that proves how short this alpha
is but also how good it is if we wanted
to go back so many times I know I really
can't wait until it comes out now one
final challenge here he was like let me
load you up with some bullets while
you're on your way out yeah I heard you
guys were thinking about finishing me
out towards the Easter Egg area okay
okay where was the ending though was it
in that area it's like back towards the
beginning okay alright see you later
captain thanks for tuning in yeah we're
actually about to wrap up after this run
ourselves but I gotta say I like it so
far and I actually really want to see
how it is when the full game comes out
because if this is just an alpha and
like a preview of what's to come then I
know they probably have a lot of other
cool abilities and a cool little easter
egg spots in store for us so that's
pretty exciting maybe let's end this
dream in
in this room there's no one left because
we ate them all yeah there it is you
guys there's a release date uh no well
you guys if you enjoyed what you saw on
the preview feel free to download the
demo yourself it is available on Steam
right now for everyone and yeah hope you
enjoyed it and thank you guys so much
for tuning in tune in every weekday at
11 a.m. Pacific time for GameSpot Live
we're playing all kinds of goodies this
week we have a lot of cool stuff on the
docket as well so yeah hope you guys
tune in thanks for watching and I'll see
ya later
see ya peace